one after another Palestinians are
leaving their homes inside einel Helwig
the refugee camp in southern Lebanon is
now a war zone
three days of fighting between rival
factions has created a humanitarian
crisis
we risk Our Lives to leave the camp just
to buy food there are no vegetables
apart from potatoes and biscuits
there are also no Health Services the
wounded and the sick are being evacuated
but it's dangerous even ambulances are
coming under Fire
the fighting is worse than the last
round a month ago it has spread to many
neighborhoods we don't know what to do
Street battles are raging in the narrow
Alleyways of a camp where at least 60
000 people live in less than two square
kilometers
Palestinian president Mahmoud abbasis
movement is responsible for security
inside the camp it's fighting a number
of groups who call themselves the Muslim
youth
the latest round of battles was sparked
by the assassination of a senior
commander of the fatah movement and
demands for his assassins to be brought
to justice but fatah officials are now
accusing the Muslim use of trying to
control the camp
outbreaks of violence are common in a
camp known for its lawlessness and life
for most people here has been one of
misery
humanitarian Aid is being blocked and
mediation efforts have so far failed to
implement a ceasefire
who is benefiting from this fighting the
only outcome is displacement why should
it be displaced again none of these
factions represent us there is fear
among a stateless people of a major
military Showdown and it wouldn't be the
First Palestinian camps have been
destroyed in violence in recent decades
unlike previous rounds of battles in
Late July fighting is no longer confined
to certain neighborhoods it's spreading
and people trapped inside say nowhere is
safe
Southern Lebanon